so I'm making brothers and sisters I
want to get into this breaking story of
a priest monk who accepted Islam this is
a quick clip of when he was formerly in
the church preaching
it's wonderful to be here this is my
first time visiting the parish here and
this is a short clip of the person I
knew him personally describing him
from when he was a priest slash monk be
very grieved over some news that I heard
yesterday and confirmed that it's true
and it's public information and
um very very sad and grieved over this
because this is in relation to somebody
that I know personally and have also
admired and um you know really sad to
see this so an Eastern Catholic priest
and monk just recently became a Muslim
father hilarion hege now I want to get
into his personal words this is from an
article that he wrote where he says one
simply can't be a priest and among
publicly and a Muslim privately and a
Muslim is simply one who submits his or
her will to the one God to the creative
heavens and earth he said in order to
begin my new life as a Muslim I felt it
important to head back East to go home
to the place where my journey to Islam
began some 20 get this 20 years ago in a
little Islamic Center in the University
Town in the Russ
belt Appalachian he said a copy of the
Quran the very word of God on my
dashboard leading the way as he's
driving to Where it All Began and where
it all began was somehow a seed was
planted he was given dawah something
happened and it resonated with him so
much so that 20 years later it blossomed
and it continued to grow as he relays in
his story so he goes on to say as a
younger middle-aged priest my life until
this point was set so he's talking about
his life is set he said I had a
promising career as a priest get this I
was well liked well educated he said
everything by all accounts was going
right yet there's a key point he says
yet my inner convictions have changed
matured perhaps but a seed planted years
ago had blossomed into full bloom
this is deep brothers and sisters this
is D brothers and sisters and people of
humanity how many of us get caught up of
worrying about a position worrying about
the certain class of people you got
everything everything's going right why
do you want to mess it up with Islam why
would you do that because it's the truth
it's the truth and he was sincere his
heart was open and he couldn't hold back
and he goes on to say in the article and
then you got to let it out
you could do it right now
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth and
every Allah and Muhammad is his
messenger and this will include all the
preceding messages that came before
Muhammad including Abraham and Moses and
Jesus peace be upon them all and
Muhammad just being the last final
messenger that's that
he goes on to say I had no choice and he
quotes
a verse from the Quran where God
Almighty Allah is saying whoever Allah
guides whoever God Almighty Gods
whatever Allah guides none can lead
astray and whoever so Allah gives
guidance for him there is no one who can
misguide
he goes on to say it is for this reason
that converts to Islam often do not
speak so much of conversion as they
speak of reversion to Islam
our pre-mortal faith a long process of
returning because as we know the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
himself he said every child is born on
the fifth or the Natural Way Islam of
that submission you are inclining
towards worshiping one and only one God
submitting yourself to the creator of
heavens and earth so now you come back
to that when you accept Islam so he
quotes this and he says that that's why
converts talk about reversion coming
back to the Natural State of a human
being uh being in that total submission
to the Creator instead of conversion
it's it's like coming home he goes on to
say the warmth and Hospitality that I
witnessed and receive from the Muslim
Community is simply phenomenal never
have I experienced such Hospitality now
I know you guys can go ahead and with
your experiences you can see remember I
was sitting with the prominent member of
the Gracie family and he also travels to
the Muslim World there doing seminars
and he talks about like many people this
Hospitality that they feel he says I go
to people's home here and
you know about you some at home where
we're at now he says man I can't even
get them to give me a glass of water and
so uh
people understand when they go and visit
the Muslim land visit the Muslims and
you'll see the difference just as
our brother here is expressing he said I
feel a peace a joy a relief might pull
towards Islam submission this is what
Islam means submission to the will of
the creator of heaven or a submission to
God the one God over 20 years has
finally led me home now begins my work
of entering deeper into the faith a
deeper learning a love for Dean meaning
the way the way this is the way of Jesus
the way of Moses the way of Abraham the
light the way of the last defination
prophet Muhammad that way of
surrendering submitting not to your
desires
not to a human being not to Angels
Saints nothing in creation but the one
God
a love for the ummah a love for Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings to be upon
them so this is the first of a
never-ending Journey Back To God
subhanallah beautiful congratulations to
our brother who goes by the name now sad
Abdul Latif and whoever can put us in
touch with him please go ahead get in
touch have him get in touch with us we
love to sit and talk with him and learn
more about his story and for those who
are sad
some of the people who've known him from
the past who've expressed some kind of
remorse we sincerely earnestly ask you
to you know him as a smart intelligent
likable human being he's got his mind on
right
he's making this decision at putting
everything on the line
you got to ask yourself
is there something here you're not going
to know unless you do the same and look
into Islam sincerely humbly look into
this Islam read the Quran
and go to the dshow.com and we'll get
you one as a gift from us to you at the
deanshow.com we'll send you one and ask
the creator of the heavens and earth
alone earnestly Guide Me Guide Me Guide
Me
thank you very much hope you enjoyed
this story as much as I have
alhamdulillah